petit grand rouge violet poilu avec une
odeur de menthe ou encore de noix de
coco les champignons regorgent de
trésors cachés
je vous laisse sentir vous pouvez sentir
sous les lames là l'odeur particulière
par contre faire attention parce qu'il y
a des clits aussi blancs qui sont
terriblement toxiques et même mortels
l'association des naturalistes des
Yvelines organisent les week-end des
sorties pédagogiques en forêt pour
sensibiliser aux champignons et sur la
vingtaine de participants des novices
mais aussi des amateurs éclairés tout
simplement parce que j'aime la nature
j'aime la mycologie j'aime la botanique
et que quand on va en forêt à cette
époxy on a toujours quelque chose à
rapporter depuis que j'ai le temps je
sors vraiment assez souvent en forêt
pratiquement ni moins une fois par
semaine minimum quoi et puis le fait de
toujours mettre un vouloir mettre un nom
sur sur chaque espèce qu'on rencontre
sur chaque petite chose puis le fait
aussi que c'est chaque champignon pour
beaucoup de champignons sont liés aussi
aux arbres au terrain etc donc je très
intéressant du coup vu que le fait aussi
de sortir en forêt tout simplement pour
faire prendre l'air
[Musique]
certains chanceux se trouve leur premier
cèpes de Bordeaux ou bien des pleurotes
en huîtres des champignons délicieux
mais pas courant l'occasion pour les
mycologues de faire le point sur les
champignons comestibles ou non des
grands comestibles il y en a une
quarantaine si vous voulez en tout on
les trouve pas tous ici mais on peut en
trouver une vingtaine sans problème en
forêt Marly on trouve de nombreuses
russules comestibles on trouve des
lépiotes les les coulemelles par exemple
à coulemelle on trouve aussi un petit
peu de girolles
on peut trouver du CEP mais cette année
en Île-de-France c'est pas très riche
parce qu'on a eu un été beaucoup trop
chaud et sec surtout en revanche déjà
une demi-heure ce matin on a trouvé pas
mal d'espèces des quelques amanides des
reçus le bonne variété de reçus des
lactaires et d'autres et d'autres et
plein d'autres champignons dans notre
département il y aurait deux à 3000
espèces de champignons attention donc
aux faux amis qui sont en fait toxiques
ou mortelles au moindre doute demandé
toujours l'expertise d'un mycologue ou
d'un pharmacien
[Musique]